once I discovered neuroplasticity I
thought I wish I'd known about this when
I was 18. you know it's literally
life-changing I think I was naturally
manifesting from about the age of 18
anyway but I didn't understand the
science behind it once you understand
that you can literally change your brain
at any stage any age any mindset it's
life-changing isn't it and I feel that
you know one of the things we were sort
of chatting about earlier is that just
because I'm a scientist and an MD it
doesn't mean that in my real life it's
easy for me to just Channel
neuroplasticity it's still odd you know
I've been through a divorce I've been
through grief I've been through career
change and those Hard Times taught me
resilience and neuroplasticity but the
hard times were almost the opportunity I
didn't want to go through those things
you can take that as an opportunity and
I think if you really understand
neuroplasticity then you can make the
worst times in your life the start of
the best time in your life and that's
what I love about neuroplasticity but
it's that ability to change to grow to
regulate your emotions which I know
you're really into and build resilience
need motivation watch it up 10 we'll
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I was making 300 bucks a
month I quit on my business partner and
the thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
taylorson from one of the best Taurus
swart and my take on our top 10 rules of
success enjoy
an example of neuroplasticity that I
would share with with you with our
listeners is
gratitude lists
so for years in my journaling I would
write 10 things I'm grateful for every
day
and they were always external things
friends family travel you know
um Financial Freedom whatever
and I literally just got bored of
writing the same things so I thought
okay what what else could I write so I
started writing things like my
creativity my vulnerability my
resilience internal things
and that was a real game changer really
what happened when you started doing
that it made me think that whatever life
throws at me I've got the tools and
resources within me to deal with it
um and and I didn't always have you know
in my 20s
I wouldn't say I was very emotionally
regulated but
learning that
whatever happens the sort of
the pendulum swing for your emotions the
higher it goes the lower it goes as well
and and bringing that to like parameters
that you're comfortable with is
that gives you sort of autonomy and
agency in life sure
um and and again that's the thing I love
about neuroplasticity well number two
think positively abundance is basically
about thinking positively it's about
believing that the world is a good place
that there's enough out there for
everyone that we're not in competition
for resources and that if somebody else
does well that doesn't mean badly for us
that if we give something to someone or
help someone with something that that's
a good thing that it generates more
positivity and that somehow you know
that that will come back to you at some
point
and interestingly it correlates to the
strongest gearing of the brain that we
have for our survival as a species which
is called loss aversion yes so um that
means that the psychological effect of
avoiding loss is about twice as powerful
as the psychological effect of the
equivalent gain or reward
and the easiest way to explain that is
um if you walked from the parking lot to
your
Studio this morning and you
found fifty dollars on the floor on your
way in you'd be probably pleasantly
surprised that you found fifty dollars
you might keep it you might give it to
charity
um but by the time you you know you're
in the studio and you've started
thinking about recording you would have
forgotten about that fifty dollars
if you walked from your car across the
parking lot you realized by the time you
got to the studio that you'd lost fifty
dollars out of your pocket you'd be mad
at yourself you'd go back out to the
parking lot to see if you could find it
you might even go back out there more
than once to check
and you might still be thinking about
that at the end of the day so that's
just an example of how the same loss or
gain has more powerful effect if we lose
and so psychologically
um anything like feeling excluded or
isolated or treated unfairly or feeling
like you don't have the same
opportunities as somebody else has that
really strong effect on your on your
brain
um and so we have to work doubly hard to
go against that because it is something
that helped us to survive in evolution
but it's
I was going to say it's not helpful in
the modern world but to be honest I will
say it's not a way to live a life
um you know it's a very
because I believe the way you think
determines your life if you believe that
everybody's out there in competition
there isn't enough out there for
everyone that you've got to like fight
to get your bit
that would just be such a sad way to
live well number three seek motivation a
strong negative motivator gets us into
action
um sometimes a really strong positive
one will do that too but not as strongly
as a negative motivator so I'm thinking
for example when I had my wedding come
up and I wanted to look a certain way
and for the whole wedding to feel a
certain way I did a lot of things I
wouldn't normally do to try to make sure
that happened but that was unusual and I
remember thinking then okay this is a
really positive motivator but most of
the time we do things to avoid a
perceived loss or we do things because
things have gone wrong for us and we
need to try to make it better and
actually that is very explained by
science because one of the strongest
gearings of our brain from evolution is
called loss avoidance and the brain is
two to two and a half times as primed to
avoid loss as it is to get a reward rule
number four be intentional the sort of
the intentionality of what you do so you
can do
the same thing like okay so intermittent
fasting is a great example there's a
huge difference between between people
who say oh I forget to eat breakfast and
people who eat like me which is only
between 12 noon and 8 PM every day
because of the intention it actually has
a different effect on your body yeah
it's like your body's like burning more
because you're intentionally doing that
or you're losing my weight or something
I won't go so far as to say it's burning
more or you're losing more weight but
there's so again in Neuroscience there's
a difference between
um intentional mind wandering and just
slipping off into daydreaming and so if
you slip off into daydreaming that means
your attention isn't the best and it's
actually kind of a bad sign in terms of
your focus and your concentration but if
you intentionally let your mind wander
then actually that leads to more
creative thinking also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business see you
there rule number five rewire your brain
the longer we have been experiencing
something the more deeply entrenched it
is in our brain
and that's why the neural Pathways that
relate to things like the values that we
hold the roles that we play in our
family in Social Circle
how boundaried we are or not
the expectations that we place on
ourselves and the secrets that we keep
can be so deeply embedded in the neural
architecture of our brains that we're
not really aware of how much they drive
our Behavior
so essentially these are subconscious or
non-conscious beliefs that drive our
thinking processes and then drive the
actions that we take in the real world
the good news is that through
neuroplasticity you can choose
Sustainable New behaviors that will
overwrite those old neural Pathways that
you have in your brain
it's important to remember that
neuroplasticity can work for good or for
bad so you also need to be so mindful of
what you're exposing your brain to
everything you see on the TV reading the
news the people that you meet and the
emotions that you experience and the
thoughts that you let go round and round
in your brain
now there's a process for embedding
sustainable Behavior change in your
brain and that starts with raised
awareness so you really have to bring
from non-conscious to conscious what it
is that's driving your behaviors and
thinking processes at the moment
you can do that through meditation
journaling therapy or just talking to
good friends
once you've identified what might be
holding you back from success what
barriers you may be placing in front of
yourself or just old patterns of
thinking and behavior that no longer
serve you you can start to focus
attention on certain situations or
relationships where these behaviors tend
to show themselves up
at first it's important just to notice
where you could have done something
differently rather than jumping straight
into action
once you've spent some time reflecting
on this and you have a few good examples
of ways that you think or behave that
you'd like to change you can start the
third step of deliberate practice
which is choosing a new way of Behaving
or choosing a new thought or positive
affirmation or Mantra that you can use
to overwrite Old unhelpful thought
patterns
and then deliberately practicing these
actions and thoughts until they become
so strongly embedded in your brain that
they become the default pathway for your
brain to send energy along
the more you repeat something and the
more emotional intensity there is
associated with it the more likely the
neurons are to wire together and form
new neural Pathways that make either new
you and give you the best life that you
can have and this is really from the
root level up it's not superficial
Behavior change it's changing the way
that you now do things
the final part of that process is about
accountability we all have so many good
intentions but we don't always see them
through and that's why an app like
living ashram or a buddy that you're
going through this Behavior change
process with really helps you to be much
more successful than if you just have
vague thoughts about changing a way of
being or acting
the evidence from really committing to a
behavior change like this is so strong
that even the field of research around
epigenetics which is the effect of the
environment on your genes shows that if
you think in a different way act in a
new way give up lifestyle behaviors that
are actually holding you back from being
the best self that you can be things
like stress smoking drinking not
exercising eating badly that you can
actually change the expression of your
genes so we all have
um parts of our genes that can be
switched on or off so even if we have
certain
um
likelihoods of getting certain diseases
or living to a certain age
through our thoughts and our behaviors
we can change some of those outcomes
pretty incredible
one way to approach this is through
positive visualization
so you can visualize yourself healthy
and well and you can really take that to
the core of you and see yourself
exhibiting these good behaviors and
visualize the outcome that that would
have for you in the future
another way of priming your brain to
make sure that you stay accountable to
these goals that you really want to
reach is to create what I call an action
board
now this is like a vision board it's a
collage of images
metaphorical or literal that represent
all the things that you really want in
life
but the scientific part says that you
also have to take goal-orientated action
towards making these things come true
you can't just sit at home and fantasize
about them coming true
so if you create an action board you
look at it every day you visualize it
coming true
and you take the actions whether it's
from the brain Body Connection actions
that you committed to or something to do
with the longer more sustainable
Behavior change and you keep doing them
you'll see the results rolling in and
this really comes back to living
ashram's motto of root level up whole
human approach to wealth to health
wealth and well-being
um so it's about really committing and
seeing that through in every aspect of
your body your thoughts your emotions
and your spirit rule number six control
your awareness the threats have changed
from physical
to psychological or social
although that threat also existed
because we could only really Thrive as
part of a tribe in the cave and that was
literally for physical warmth as well as
affection and you know looking after
each other's children and sharing
responsibilities now there aren't as
many any in that way anyway physical
threats to our our safety or our life
but the social threat of being rejected
being lonely being abandoned
um that's still very very strong in our
wiring
um and then other things because
obviously now we have money for example
that the idea of losing your job losing
your lifestyle those have become you
know sort of potential social threats to
your safety as well and you know there's
so many more but I would say that
financial and relational have become the
biggest threats to our safety so
I think obvious examples of that are
staying in a relationship where you're
not really happy but you think well it's
better than being single again kind of
thing
um
and
because that wiring has been there for
so long and of course in Lacey's work
she talks about wiring that has been
there since childhood for us as
individuals and we have you know made it
very clear that the longer an issue has
been there the harder it is to
um bring it from subconscious to
conscious and then deal with it this is
even beyond that this is for Generations
in Millennia so it's a very strong
default and it's really every decision
that you make is based on is the world a
safe place can I do this and still be
healthy and happy and you mentioned a
specific which is not watching the news
well I don't know any neuroscientists
that I'm friends with who watches the
news and and that's the reason because
because we're wired to default to loss a
virgin if we continually tell our brain
that there's danger out there there's
bad people out there there's accidents
out there
you will not want to you take the
healthy risks that you could to make
your life better because you're too
aware of the possible dangers rule
number seven master your emotions do you
remember I mentioned the um I mentioned
six ways of thinking I may not have
classified them as the brain agility
model you said what's the source and I
said it's your fully integrated brain
power
and so I put that into six categories
which are mastering your emotions
knowing yourself which is the brain Body
Connection trusting your gut which is
intuition making good decisions it's
logic logic has to be in there but it's
just one of the six
um staying motivated and resilient to
reach your goals and then the final one
which is kind of the culmination of
those five is
um creating the life that you desire so
in that model
I talk about using all of the different
ways that you have to think
to to manifest real world outcomes but
I'd also like to say at this point that
I was one of those people who was told
at school that I wasn't creative because
I wasn't good at art
brother brother John was it was ovarian
Catholic High School sent me to the
Headmaster saying I couldn't be the
possibly be this bad at Art I must be
painting this way just to piss him off
oh
and look look what you've created right
I'm still Shake though if you give me a
paintbrush it literally it and someday I
will get to challenge myself on that but
that like the root beer is still in me
well do you remember that quote from the
book
um
somebody tells you
tells you
um so I think you know I want to give
that to you as a as a gift
um
but yeah I mean things like that stay
with you for ages if you're like 11 and
you're told that you're not creative I
believed I wasn't creative till I was
35. I fully believed I was not creative
and all my friends are creative creative
and the obvious sense of the word and I
sort of thought isn't it strange how all
my friends are created but I'm not and
there were a few friends that said but
you are but I was so shut off to
believing that that was true that I
didn't even question it or say what do
you mean or you know explore it
um so for me there was like a bang kind
of you know a crisis moment that changed
everything but one of the reasons I
wrote The Source is that that it
shouldn't have to be like that we could
you know we can all bring that into our
lives without necessarily having a
crisis so so I wanted to reframe
creativity and just make it about
creating your own life
um
and and so man so manifestation is
basically
believing that you have more agency
around creating you know what you want
in your life rather than that life just
happens to you
um I totally understand that it feels
like that for people a lot of the time
um and you know I use this analogy where
I say if if you're going on a journey a
car journey and
um would you rather be the person in the
driving seat choosing the destination
and how you get there or are you happy
to be in the passenger seat and just be
driven around not know where you're
going and you know the the route that
you take
and so a lot for a lot of people life
can feel like you're in the passenger
seat and understanding Neuroscience is
about putting yourself in the driver's
seat
so the manifestation part is how much
can you contribute to actually bringing
into your life the things that you
really really want and so it's a bit of
a gray area because to me it overlaps
with Magnetic desire which is something
that you really really want so there's
to be a strong emotional component to it
and then the actions that draw that into
your life so I'm not one of those people
that says if you visualize something or
make a vision board or
you know imagine an ideal future that
you should just wait for it to come true
because you thought about it I'm very
much about doing the actions that um
move you know progress you towards that
goal becoming true
and so um the science around
manifestation and magnetic desire and
vision boards is a three-step concept in
the brain which is selective attention
selective filtering and value tagging
and basically we're bombarded with so
much information all the time everything
we smell here see everyone we meet but
the brain naturally filters most of that
out and
um brings our attention to the things
that are relevant for our survival and
to tags those things in order of
importance and there's both a logical
and an emotional component to why
certain things are important to us
so you can imagine if you're trying to
hold down the day job if you're trying
to put food on the table that
that filtering process happens quite
automatically and it's not thinking
what's the best thing that could ever
happen to me in my life well how do I
really want my life to look like in five
years time it's not doing that it's just
doing how do I survive like in the next
short term
so um
paying attention to manifestation
and one of the mediums for doing that as
a vision board is a way of priming your
brain to notice and grasp opportunities
that might otherwise have passed you by
well number eight find a coach if your
brain has seen something
or experienced it through mental
rehearsal then
when it comes across something similar
in real life it's less threatening
so uncertainty is the most threatening
thing to your brain anything new is a
huge threat to your brain which is kind
of counter to neuroplasticity right
because with neuroplasticity I make
myself do something new every year so
I've learned several languages really
yeah how many languages do you know now
um I've learned five in my life I'm not
going to pretend
um are you fluent in any yeah so I was
very lucky I was brought up bilingual in
English in an Indian language and then
from the age of nine I learned French at
school wow um
and then as an adult I learned three
other languages at different times
um probably not so good at those ones
um yeah so during the pandemic
I
I actually made a statement in the
beginning which was
don't necessarily put pressure on
yourself to like start a new career or
learn a language then it went on for
longer than we all thought it would
um so I was actually on an Instagram
live saying that I'd always wanted to
learn the piano
and somebody sent me a DM and said Dr
Tara you can use the flow key app to
teach yourself piano Loki huh yeah
um it's a really really cool app and um
I'd been gifted a piano keyboard for
Christmas by my husband I am ashamed to
say a year or two earlier and never used
it
um so in the pandemic I did I did use
the Floki app and teach myself
um now you know how to play piano
yeah and
um my husband gave me tennis lessons and
then I thought okay if I can learn piano
and I can learn tennis and I can see how
much I improve and I can see the muscle
memory from when I played tennis and
when I was at High School
can I apply that to
looking at life through a happier lens
so it's a natural default for all of us
to you know loss aversion is one of the
biggest gearings of the brain and is
essential to survival lost aversion yeah
so avoiding loss
and uncertainty like I said we don't
like that so we like things to be safe
we like them to be the same you know we
like to know what's going to happen
and and equally we like you know the
brain wants to look out for danger to
protect us
and during the pandemic I'd been
speaking for a few years about having a
sabbatical and a few people said to me
oh now you can have a sabbatical
and I said you know I'm locked up at
home I can't travel I can't see my
friends I can't hug my stepson it's not
a sabbatical it's not the sabbatical I
dreamed of and also
the mental health requirements was so
vast that I felt I had to do my piece
and really you know speak to that
through Instagram through zoom and try
to help people so I was actually busier
with work than ever before trying to
help people yeah but I did start you
know I saw a lot of relationship
breakups I saw a lot of people get sick
you know a lot of people that I
personally knew died during the pandemic
and
it was easy to start to feel like to
focus on things like you can't see
people you can't travel and
I didn't
I didn't want to see myself go down that
road
so I actually I got a coach you know I
believe in having therapy having
coaching having supervision I love it
um and I worked on on that and she
actually said to me why can't you apply
neuroplasticity to being happier
and because it's intangible it's you
know you can make a vision board with a
house and you know a
a dream holiday and vacation for the
material world exactly how do you create
one for the emotional world I think
there are and that's why imagery is
important because it can evoke a feeling
yes
um but I remember the moment I was
standing sort of at the door to my
garden
and a really small nice thing had
happened and I thought isn't that lovely
and and I I actually checked myself and
I thought I notice when something goes
wrong all the time
I don't always acknowledge when
something goes right or is really good
and happy and so I could tell that I had
I had changed that I was noticing those
things you didn't notice that before I
mean I'm sure I did sometimes with like
big things rule number nine practice
gratitude we've developed an
appreciation for things that we may have
taken for granted before so I have been
um in lockdowns I've been with one other
person and it has certainly made me
think
at first I was like well if I'd been on
my own I would have been fine but as the
months drag on and as it happens again
and again I just my heart just is
so out there for people who've been
through that on their own that is not a
healthy state for us and so a lot of the
work I've done in the last year is to
encourage people to bathe rather than
shower because immersing yourself in
warm water releases the same bonding
hormones that you get from physical
affection from a loved one
to massage your own body to do gratitude
practices that involve self-touch
um so a lot more you know being a lot
more proactive about the fact that you
maybe can have been isolated alone but
also even with one affectionate person
or you know two or three affectionate
people in your family it's normal in a
day to go out and shake hands or hug or
kiss like eight to twelve people and so
that happens and you don't even really
think about it and they say that you
need eight hugs a day just to sort of
stay mentally stable and 20 hugs a day
to grow as a you know as a person who
feels
healthy and happy and they can take some
risks so I think suddenly demanding 20
hugs a day from one person is probably
you know so angle number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
learn to forgive I think we've I think
we've said a lot there's one thing that
I didn't write about in the book as much
as I would have liked you and that's
forgiveness
um and actually you reminded me about
that by talking about Hawaii
um
and because I did some research into the
ho open opo when I was writing the book
I'm sure you know all-time favorite yeah
you know about it way better than me and
I don't want to you know to do it to
disjustice but when I struggled with
forgiveness I asked so many people I
read about it I you know listened to
meditations and and you know a version
of the Hawaiian
um forgiveness
meditation was what was what really
worked for me so
um
it's very simple the version that I do
is to think of the person that you're
struggling to forgive and say
um thank you I love you
I'm sorry I forgive you I release you
but you have to keep saying it until you
mean it and it can be hard at times but
when you get there
it changes your life
the scientific version of that really is
that the way that you think determines
what happens in your life
and again you know it's something I've
been speaking about for so long but it's
more crucial than ever now because it's
so easy to think negatively now but it's
so easy to feel down to feel out of
control
um to hear what everybody else is saying
and just get swept up in that and that's
why things like the journaling and the
affirmation and the action board are so
important because they can really help
to keep you focused on the fact that the
way that you think is going to make the
difference between surviving and
thriving
and again hopefully we all have a bit
more time now to really do what's called
metacognition which is think about our
thinking so not just let the outside
world happen to us but take more agency
over the way that we think and react to
things
so finally I just wanted to say that
what the science really points at with
all those tips behind us is that your
mental resilience or your inner strength
whatever you like to call it is the key
differentiator in terms of how people
are going to deal and cope
even in the same circumstances so you
know there's there's you that will
struggle with something and then there's
the best you that will get through it
that will inspire others and will come
out feeling better and stronger and I
believe in that you and the science
really backs it up so please believe
that you're remarkable that you can do
things that you never thought you could
do before and let's all do it together
in community
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Rhonda Byrne
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there there's no effort
involved when you're fighting when
you're pushing you don't believe that
you have what you're wanting it's not
going to come you're going to keep
creating not having it because you're
creating all the time so you either